تحاول احلام عدلي منذ اربع سنوات الحصول
على الطلاق ولا يكفي راتبها الذي يقل عن
100 دولار في الانفاق على اطفالها الثلاثه
بينما يتهرب الزوج من الانفاق على اطفاله
او الطلاق
اكيد هيساعد معي في الثلاث عيال اللي انا
شايلاهم لوحدي
والدروس كلها
[موسيقى]
في قضايا الطلاق الذي تصل نسبته الى
36% يتم الان وضعه قانون جديد للاحوال
الشخصيه اتضحت بعد موده ومن بينها
للمقبلين على الزواج ضروره اجراء كشف طبي
شامل واجراء تحليلا للمخدرات الى جانب منح
صلاحيات جديده للقاضي وتحديد الذمه
الماليه للزوجين وانشاء صندوق لرعايه
الاسره ووثيقه تامين لدعمها في مواجهه
النفقات والتحديات ذات الصله وخاصه في حال
حدوث الطلاق
هذا الصندوق بيتكفل بدعم الاسره في
اوقاتها الحرجه زي اللي سيادتك تفضلت بها
كده طب الدعم بتاعه هيجي منين سيادتك
تفضلت ان الحكومه حتشاهم في هذا الصندوق
بقدر ما يساهم فيه
المتزوجين
المبالغ التي سيدفعها المقبل على الزواج
في الصندوق الجديد حتى الان الا ان جدلا
كبيرا اثير على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
وسط الخشيه من ارتفاع المبالغ المطلوبه
وهو مقد يؤدي الى الالتفاف حول الشروط
الموضوع في القانون الجديد
وهو على حسب المبلغ بصراحه يعني انا ما
اعرفش اول مبلغ كم في ناس بتقول 30,000
وفي ناس بتقول 20 وانا مش عارف الحياه فين
بصراحه لكن لو هو المبلغ ده هو المبلغ
كبير جدا طبعا انا مع صندوق دعم الاسره
قلبا وقالبا لان المراه حقها مهدور وبيقف
دورها عند ان هي تاخذ حكم المحكمه وحليني
بقى عشان ننفذ واقي القبض على احد
العاملين في مكتب ماذون حتى المواطنين
بالاصرار في عقد قرانهم قبل اقرار القانون
لتلافي دفع مبالغ وصفها بالباهظه اي جهه
من الجهات الرسميه في الدوله تكلمت ان هو
المقبل على زواجها يسدد الصندوق 30,000
جنيه هذا الشخص بمجرد الفحص تبين ان هو مش
ماذون اصلا قانون الاحوال الشخصيه الجديده
اثار جدلا قبل اقراره جدل متوقع قد يدفع
القائمين عليه لتعديل بعد موده قبل طرحه
على الحكومه والبرلمان راند ابو العزم
العربيه القاهره